Hi, Amanda.
Good morning.
Having.
Uh, I mean the shall we start with the updates?
Yeah, let's go ahead and go.
Thank you.
The basement validation part from our side, we made few changes on Thursday and provided the PBX file and that has been updated by ambit as well.
And also we did validate a few of the KPI's which you mentioned in your email that that has been validated from our end and we are in the final stage of validation and we would require another 20-30 minutes after this call for us to confirm everything is fine and then we'll upload the updated version and then form that for A to push it to the pre prod environment and we'll let you know once she confirms.
The refresh is complete.
OK.
Thank you.
And.
On one phase, two have been on the development side.
It is complete right from our side.
Yes.
OK, so we have migrated all the modules like pick up and also delivery tool.
The Azure functions right now since we don't have the connectivity between the DB and the Azure functions.
Currently we are utilizing Azure storage just to mock the particular environment where we store the CSV and take it for preprocessing 10 for feature engineering and so on.
So we are trying to exactly replicate the same and draw from Azure storage for now.
So once we are, once we get the connect connection string for the DB like we'll like try to replace the other storage with the actual DB and everything will look like as as expected.
So that's the overall update.
What I got so as of now like the entire workflow from preprocessing till model development is working in Azure functions.
OK.
Did we?
So, Andrew, yeah, sorry you score.
Umm, I know we changed a couple fields like the sources.
Are we also making that change and the and the data model too?
Yes.
Or the retraining. OK.
Yeah.
Then yeah, we have done that, so.
OK.
Thank you.
Sorry if I missed that.
Yeah, I do.
I have a request on the status of creating the database access for us.
I will.
I will meeting with the data team.
I think after this so I'll double check with them.
I think they started creating it.
I'm not sure what the status is right now.
OK, so you if we get that then then we we can plan to.
Implement the change with the database into the function app and then well.
We'll start moving it to pretty proud as well for everyone's review.
OK.
So once that is done, please let us know.
Yep, we'll do.
And for the dashboard development of on the EDA insights that has been complete for both pickup and delivery.
Jamal can be present that to the team.
Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
So that let me share my screen.
Yeah.
It is feasible, let us know.
That my screen is usually.
Yeah, suitable, yes.
Ohh, so uh, this is an EDA insights like you know we have already share our PowerPoint presentation.
What we have got the result in the Edu insights, so the same we have tried to know replicated in our power BI dashboards, OK, so just go through 1 by 1 the dashboards so so if the first first charge is representative, so top five went or based on the pickup.
So the vendor wise, the top pickup count, it's not a pickup point, it's it's a shipment.
Shipment happened for the vendor wise.
So based on that, we just you know.
I'm showing us an insight has top five vendors.
At present we are just showing the vendor code.
Is that fine or else so we just want you to showcase the the vendor name because we notice the same vendor code has multiple vendor names.
So it means it's not a meaningful to showcase them when their name.
That is the reason we just showcasing the vendor code is that fine or any other way to showcase the based on the vendor code with some shipment or shipment counts.
I just pause here.
If you have any some suggestion to know improve this analysis of the first part of charts, let us know we will ready to do that.
When you hover over, but any outlet, yeah that there so still just the vendor code pics as listed.
It doesn't say the name.
Are there multiple vendor names, Sherry because of the GMs and the mover suite ID?
Why would there?
How could there be multiple names?
No, there's one vendor code, 1 vendor code should have only one name.
But with I mean, but even with the duplicates it should technic because we we are having some issues with duplicates in the system because of mover suite.
Right.
So.
But it should still have the same name if we're pulling.
Right now there could be, yeah.
The we'll do one thing we just know showcase the name in the tool tip.
Let's see how it's some.
OK.
These are it's visible.
We'll see that.
OK.
Yeah, I know that there are similar like vendor names like it could.
It could be very similar, right?
And there to another vendor name.
But they're vendor codes are different, so that's the distinction.
Yeah.
Yes, sure.
Yeah, because it could be different locations, yeah.
Umm.
Yeah, we we notice like for a vendor code you 1398 for example if the U1398IS sad that and we notice the same mentor code has a different name as the Sadat Inc in the different row items.
So these are all the the name mismatches we found.
So that is the reason we just showcasing only based on the vendor code here.
Yeah.
From that we may be stuck if if if there are the mismatch is like that.
Where are you pulling the name from?
Is it from the vendor the the vendor dimension?
The EM vendor.
Yeah, the vendor.
Yeah, DM vendor.
Yes, exactly.
Yeah, it should be.
What?
Just the legal name.
That should be the field that we pull from.
I know there it may be called like other things and like other, but I think the the legal name, I think that's what it's called now.
I have to look at it because I might be thinking of scacs, yeah.
Yeah, I do know.
Legal name as part of like stack, but like maybe?
So you you meant a column attribute name is legal name.
I think so, but I might be thinking of the scac the **** code because I'm also working on scats and separately.
OK.
Can you can you verify which field we should be using? Sherry.
Yeah, let me.
OK.
I'm trying to get a vendor.
Thank you.
Umm centercode.
It's up.
Do you have vendor?
Yep, Yep.
It might just be vendor name.
Vendor code and went our name.
I remember that.
Yeah, maybe it is just vendor name.
Let me see.
Yep, it's just vendor name.
That's all that it says.
Yep.
So that's the name that we should be using.
Is the vendor name?
Yep, from the vendor table and that, yeah, there will be like multiple ACE relocation systems because they're different.
Hmm locations.
Yeah.
So you can use vendor name because when we're looking into the table like into the report, they're mostly going to be looking by area.
I'm sure like the origin and destination areas, and then when that vendor pulls up, they'll know which one it is just.
Vendor name.
So instead vendor code we can use the vendor name or else we just show that tool tip as vendor name.
That is fine.
Yeah.
Which one do you want, Amanda?
Umm, I can only have one vendor code.
UM, if, like the way you're hovering now.
The bar chart.
That, yeah.
OK.
Like I like the code being in the the the card, the bar chart.
Thank you.
And then the vendor name to pop up in the tool tip.
When you hover it, yes?
Yeah. Yep.
Yeah. Yes.
Yeah, that is.
If that's possible without it being too complicated, OK.
Yeah, that is doable.
That is doable.
Ohh no, it's super simple.
It's not an issue, yeah.
OK.
OK, so the so can we go on for the next one?
Is that fine, right?
Yeah.
The only changes is we have to include the tool tip of vendor name.
OK, so the and.
Under I just wanna look at the the filters at the top.
So the does this filter or does the top five in theory could change based off of the performance period we select?
Is that correct?
Do any of the filters at the top?
Below the data will follow those OK.
Yes, yes.
Yesterday interaction you supply, yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
Uh.
So yeah, the changes.
You know, yeah.
So the another one is and the pick up time period with most of shipment happened.
So we just, you know, segregated the shipment type based on the shipment.
Sorry, shipment count based on the shipment type and the month on month trend, we just showing us so which month we has more shipments happened?
I was surprised there.
I'm so with this.
Did which vendor code did you use?
So did you use the OA vendor code or the HA vendor code?
Which?
No you here.
They're counting pickup by pickup date, GBL by pickup date.
Ohh, just a month, not vendor.
Yes.
OK, got it. OK.
Yeah, it's vendor.
It's not included here.
No worries.
We don't need to add it.
I I misunderstood what I was thinking.
Yeah.
So just a shipment type wife shipments.
Glasgow domestic loose Q pack.
Think have a lot.
So right now we just showcasing as your account of Gmail number.
So instead of count of GBL number we will change it to shipments number of shipments.
Now you wouldn't have thought Cube pack would be that much higher in July.
Then and van or the.
Yeah, because the the colors are changing.
Signs of money.
So the another one is the time period with the most delays.
Like no, we had segregated the pickup status like moderate delay 10 to 30 days and significant delays beyond 35 days and slide delays.
So one to 10 days.
So based on the segregations, so we just showcasing month on one that and the shipments happened.
Yeah, it's.
How do you define the delay? What?
The based on the plan pickup date and the actual pickup date.
OK.
Umm, that works, yeah.
The plan data is is what we enter when we do the premise survey.
Umm.
The the date range, the days, the ranges of the days? Umm.
One, as you said, 10 to 30.
So I don't know.
I need to think about how what those ranges would be because.
Flight 1 to 10.
Significant 35.
So if you wanted to change the bucket that also it's doable.
So you just know if there is any changes to segregate the buckets, you just send us an email or.
Whatever.
OK.
Just messages how the bucket would be.
So we will do it, we'll do the changes based on your.
OK.
Thank you.
Together, yeah.
Channel and Orange state.
Is that fine?
Shall I go to the next one?
Yeah.
The time period with most delays is fine.
Now the count of vendor by channel and origin state. Hmm.
Yeah, that Channel cherry which you shared us the channel.
So what are?
Yeah, the regions are at the bottom.
The destination regions are on the X axis and then the origin states are the the colors and the bar chart shush.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Very interesting.
Yeah, this ones a little well, I keep looking down to the bubbles, but yeah, that that visual is a little.
Umm.
So this is how many vendors in a chat in a channel.
Yeah.
I state.
The count of vendor by channel.
Actually it is count of shipment.
Ohh it's shipment count.
Yeah, actually we need to rename relabel it.
OK.
So count of shipment for the origin state for the particular channel.
That that will change the name, yeah.
Is that helpful to you, Amanda?
Umm, I don't know.
It could be and I'm just not.
There's six.
Or do we say Texas?
OK, from Texas to region six, we had 25133 shipments pick up, is that correct?
Yes.
OK.
And where we've got it all performance periods.
Exactly.
OK.
So if you wanted to change any particular performance period, you will have to.
Ohm.
Yeah.
When.
No, no, that's OK.
There we go.
That is, it is pretty interesting.
Yeah, I know.
That's why.
So yeah, I do think that that will be helpful.
So now we're looking at.
Vendor code and OK.
Yeah, if we just.
Yeah.
We just change it instead of counting vendor account to shipment or GBL or whatever.
Yeah, that works.
Yeah, I know that is very interesting.
OK.
I think we can go to the next one.
You know, ohh.
This is shipment type based on the weight and the locations.
So pick up state was.
So shipment type is Alaska and pick up Windows 8 is Alabama and the average of shipment actual weight is 3001 zero 4.76.
So Rhoda Georgio India now.
Thanks guys.
Is this this?
Can you hover on the domestic list?
Is this the sum of the way or the average weight?
Average.
Average of shipment actual weight.
You meant hovering over the domestic loose load like the first balloon.
I think blue bar.
Uh, can we go down to the domestic loose load shipment type?
Perfect. OK.
To pick up from Alabama as 81, OK.
Do we go to the Gray?
Rhoda, OK.
Umm, so in the the the key at the top, the last state we see as Kansas, but there was an arrow do we can we click that arrow and it pulls like we can see?
This one.
No up.
Up in the key where it says Georgia, Indiana, Kansas, like right underwear, the title is where it says shipment, weight and location.
Yeah.
So there's Indiana, there's Kansas, but there's a lot more states.
So that what we do, OK.
Yeah.
OK.
So we have your scroll option, is there yeah.
We need to use DPS net weight.
For that not shipment actually.
From the DPS?
It's it's in shipment detail, but it's that's the name of it is DPS net weight.
So we have the same the similar column is there in the DPS shipment table.
You mean right?
Oh yeah.
DPS shipment?
Yeah, it's probably there too, yes.
I think.
So instead of which we using the shipment detail table, we have to use DPS shipment.
The same column attributes before that we need to check the column is there or not.
OK, let me look and see what's there.
Actual act, CT, net weight.
That's the column in DPS shipment.
Eight years.
AC T for actual.
OK.
So it'll be, yeah, ACT net weight.
Umm, the shipment actual way?
Is from our core system, so I will not.
I don't trust that.
Yeah.
OK so.
I mean, if there's DPS, if there's data and DPS that's that should always be, we should.
You have any dates or weights need to come from the DPS data and nothing not from anything that we have internally because it's more human error.
OK, so not at all.
So we will change accordingly, Sherry.
OK.
Yeah, but that's interesting.
So are all the states listed there.
That's where our in that card.
Even when we use the arrow, I don't think they were all listed.
Yeah.
My only we have all the States 50 plus instead in this chat.
Or have we districted to 10 nodes?
Uh, right now we have restricted for top 10.
OK.
Yeah, I think that's fine because otherwise it's going to get really crazy.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, it's look like a clumsy.
Yes. Yeah.
She don't see what are the numbers.
OK, at least we understand.
Like that's fine.
It's the top ten that's.
Yeah, I mean, and if you, I mean, at some point in the future, if there's something else, it's easy to change the visual just to pull in something else you wanna see.
OK.
Got it.
Yeah, we can leave this one as is.
The same thing come.
This is based on the vendor, so instead of based on the shipment type, we just showcasing the top five pick up vendor based on shipment weight.
So here also we will change the shipment actual weight from shipment details too DPS shipment or table.
Remind you have doubt.
Top six think we need to change it.
Yeah, that will change.
OK, I'll do that.
OK.
Yeah, that works.
Umm.
So that the another one is the bubble chart represents it's consistency, went out pick up performance.
So the top one is W 07590.
Number of shipment is 228 and the performance so based on the at number of shipments and the top average on time pickup score.
So this is the one is the first one the the Topper vendor.
So we'll do include the vendor name in the tool tip here itself.
We will do that.
We'll do the changes here.
OK.
OK, so the size of the bubble is the count shipment count, right?
Exactly.
Ohh.
So based on the shipment.
OK, said the bigger I was. Yeah.
So the bigger the bubble, that means the more shipments that they handled.
Exactly.
So and was that so?
That means it's a very well performing vendor because they've handled a lot of shipments but they're also have a high score.
At 24, yeah.
So, but this W 01265 it has only number of shipment is 3 so that the bubble size is pretty small.
They're not very timely either.
So this one is big face, yeah.
I don't know who that is.
The color represents a based on the vendor code the legend names.
Yeah, interesting.
So what I like with one of the filters at the top, we could select just a vendor.
Yeah, vendor code or even a couple. Right?
Umm.
Yeah, that's a lot.
And then we could see more on them, cause right now that's like, Oh my goodness, that's that's a lot of overlapping stuff, but.
Hmm.
But yeah, cause mostly I mean you're gonna be looking like by state or by, you know performance period or things like that.
So that'll yeah, that will help it.
Yeah, cool.
Oh my gosh, look at that green one.
So you you can do, you can do multiple selections also.
Yeah.
Ah, OK.
So whatever the vendor code you want, you can select a multiple selections to see the.
Very cool.
Those winter codes informations as well.
I think maybe yeah.
Umm do we?
Looking at it at a network would probably be helpful too.
Do we?
I know I don't think we've done anything with network anywhere else.
Are we tied into that data warehouse?
Could they pull that in easily sharing?
And.
Do you want a filter for network?
Yeah.
So like the A1 Freeman network or the South Network?
Like how to see how they perform, you know overall.
And then we would still have the breakdown per state.
So that's pretty cool.
And I know it looks like there's not a lot of real estate at the top to add that filter, but I think that that would, I know Jamie and and Scott Kelly would probably wanna know how the vendors are doing at the network level.
Yeah, that's in the vendor table and it's all it is, just network is the name of the the field.
OK.
And I think it would be fine just to do it at the top right was a filter.
We wouldn't necessarily need to worry about doing anything else with the other visuals.
OK.
We'll we'll look into it and.
So do do you have?
Do you want all the filters which are currently above, or can we replace any of the filter?
Umm can you go?
Uh.
Perfect vendor code, vendor state, SCAC performance, market type.
I don't think we can replace any.
OK.
Umm.
There's one that's a maybe, but I know two months down the road and they're like, man, I wish I wouldn't have asked them to remove that.
You know.
No, no issues.
I mean that will will I just check out English and we'll add it.
OK.
Thank you.
OK, we'll try to include them.
So one more filter for a network, yeah.
They were the last one.
I like this next visual.
That's really nice.
There's one.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah.
Yeah, I pick up stay and then.
Separates shipment type by the the average by the score.
Yeah, the base and the pickup state shipment type, yes.
Look at Idaho to Alaska.
Ohh, I hope that's only one shipment.
No surprise there.
Hopefully me too, Sherry.
I hope we're not we.
Is it if in the tool tip is there shipment count?
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Just fun.
Do we have shipment count and?
In the tool tip, it is their shipment count, just as a just being absolutely curious.
No, only the scores we have, yeah.
OK, OK.
Yeah, so it won't.
It's a metric table, so using the metrics table we just using the condition formatting to showcasing the numbers.
OK, OK.
Yeah, if you just click on it.
If you I think we could answer that question for you, though Sherry couldn't we just change it at the top to just Idaho, right?
Uh, but if you if you click on it, all the other visuals will change.
OK.
Yeah.
So I don't have to change out the filter.
So it would umm.
Yeah.
Gotcha.
Very cool.
So if you wanted to click any scores, it will be changing all the visuals.
OK, yeah.
Yeah, very cool.
Thanks.
Yeah.
We don't want anything out of Connecticut.
Now it's. Yeah.
That's good.
That that's a good result.
That's the result we would like to see a blank for loose load anyway.
Ohh yes, it's for shipments, yeah.
For too many.
Interesting.
So.
So the same has been applied for delivery as well.
Delivery eating, yeah.
All the yeah.
Can we?
That the only change is is time period which we used here for required delivery date and the actual delivery date.
So rest are there all the same.
Umm.
Did can we just confirm that we're using the DPS RDD and the DPS actual delivery date on all the cards?
Uh, yes, Amanda.
Perfect.
So previously we were used shipment details.
Now we changed.
After we confirm, we got confirmation from you people.
Someone.
OK, turn around like a broken record.
Just wanna it changes, it changes the results, so that's that's the only reason why it's that important to me.
Yeah, I've got it.
Change render destinations.
So we will do the changes, whatever the changes or we discussed today and we will get back to you with the updated one uh, the next meeting.
OK.
My damn sure, yeah.
Yes.
And I'll and I'll look at the delays as well to try to change the buckets and that can I'll do it for pick up and delivery.
But I really kind of want it to be the same, so I'll I'll get that out this morning.
OK.
Yeah, sure.
I need to get some feedback from our OPS people and I don't wanna make that decision without their input.
Sure.
OK, but yeah.
Umm.
It.
So.
This is very exciting.
Now this is going to replace our vendor power BI report.
I think Sherry.
Uh.
To a certain degree anyway.
Could.
Yeah.
OK.
So that's all from us for today, so.
Look great.
Thank you so much.
It was wonderful.
Yes.
OK.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Like your team?
Have a great day.
Great night.
Thank you.
OK.
Alright, bye.
Bye bye.